en este vídeo voy a intentar hacer un
nuevo ejercicio acerca de ecuaciones
diferenciales no homogéneas pero que en
un principio va a parecer extremadamente
difícil o muy rimbombante pero no se
preocupen ni se vayan a asustar creo que
se den cuenta de esta ecuación
diferencial estoy haciendo muchas
trampas con los vídeos anteriores espero
que este acuerdo no voy a tomar la
cuestión de mi prima menos 37 prima
menos 4 y la parte no la parte homogénea
que ya me había tomado siempre y la
parte no mojen de va a ser 3 a la 2 x
más dos veces el seno de x más y más a
vertical que sean los vídeos pasados lo
mismo que los vídeos pasados muy bien
esto sumamos más 4 veces x cuadrado
bien si estos eran los tres vídeos
pasados en las tres partes no homogéneas
y si uno lo ve al principio dice guau
esto suena muy difícil como lo voy a
resolver o no pero tengan cuidado tengan
paciencia no va a ser tan difícil lo
primero que voy a hacer es lo que he
venido haciendo siempre en cada vídeo
resolver la parte homogénea y la parte
homogénea pues me dice que lleve prima
menos 3 y prima menos 4 y tiene que ser
igual a 0 bien como lo tengo igualado a
cero esto quiere decir que la solución
de la parte homogénea general era hace 1
por ea la 4 x + c 2 por el ala menos x
espero que ustedes se acuerden que esta
era la solución general dependía de las
raíces pero bien ahora dese cuenta de
una cosa muy importante que mi prima
menos 3 y prima menos 4 y igualdad 32 x
esto lo habíamos resuelto en el primer
vídeo si en el primer vídeo que habíamos
hecho y como lo resolvimos en el primer
vídeo que habíamos hecho la solución
particular era menos un medio de e
2x ustedes pueden revisar los vídeos
cuantas veces quieran para ver que si
era la solución particular bien ahora
vamos a hacer lo propio con la segunda
función me quedaba el yemen prima menos
3 de prima menos 4 igual a 2 veces el
seno de x y si nosotros hacemos memoria
estos vimos en el segundo vídeo
la solución general no no la solución
particular me quedaba menos 5 entre 17 x
y esto le sumaba a 3 entre 17 sé no
estoy diciendo no no no no no tiene que
ver con el seno era menos 5 entre 17 el
seno de x muy bien más 3 sobre 17 el
coseno de x bien no me hagan caso
ok y ahora yo voy a agarrar la otra
ecuación diferencial de segundo orden no
homogénea pero que era igual a 4x
cuadrada esto es lo vimos en el último
vídeo bien y yo también ya tenía mi
solución particular mi solución
particular era a ver hagamos memoria - x
cuadrada ya estoy yo le sumaba tres
medios de x y yo le restaba menos 13
octavos bien ya tengo mis tres
soluciones particulares y yo lo que
quiero proponer es que la suma de mis
tres soluciones particulares sean la
solución particular de esta ecuación
diferencial rimbombante y de hecho tiene
mucho sentido no es así porque yo sé que
cada una de estas soluciones
particulares cumplía para cada una de
nuestras ecuaciones que ya habíamos
resuelto fíjense si yo pongo esta
primera solución particular en la
ecuación diferencial pues cumple para 3
en la 2 x si yo pongo mi segunda
solución particular en esta ecuación
diferencial pues cumple para dos veces
seno de x y si hago lo propio para la
tercera solución particular pues cumple
para 4x cuadrada y si después yo pongo
la solución homogénea pues esto era
igual a cero entonces no le sumo nada
que quiere decir todo esto pues que
quiere decir que ya encuentre
introducción general
en general va a ser la suma de cada una
de mis particulares más la solución de
homogénea es decir que esta ecuación
pelu de rimbombante ya tiene solución
general muy bien ahora lo que voy a
hacer es escribir sea solución general
pero creo que está hecho esto un poco de
relajo vamos a borrar algunas cositas
esto lo voy a borrar hasta aquí y esto
lo voy a borrar hasta acá no no no no
aquí
primero y esto lo voy a borrar y ahora
sí con color azul para bebé pondré la
solución general que va a ser c 1 x
a la 4 x + c 2 x
- x y ahora carlos la otra menos un
medio d
2x y ahora voy a seguir aquí abajo menos
5 entre 17 seno de x y a esto le tengo
que sumar 3 sobre 17 cosenos de x
y después - x cuadrada más tres medios
de x menos 13 18 amos
respiro ya por fin tengo mi solución
general ya la tengo
y al ver esta solución general pues
parece algo abrumadora y algo
impresionante pero si nosotros teníamos
nuestra ecuación diferencial que parecía
imposible de resolver pues ya lo
resolvimos entonces no estaba tan
difícil pero todo esto fue gracias a
nuestra teoría de coeficientes
indeterminados si nosotros no supiéramos
coeficientes indeterminados no hubieran
sido nada sencillos de resolverlo y es
que la solución general pues no es ni
más ni menos más que la suma de todas
las soluciones particulares de cada uno
de los sumandos más la ecuación
homogénea en los siguientes vídeos vamos
a ver otra forma de resolver este tipo
de ecuaciones diferenciales de segundo
orden así que nos vemos en el siguiente